hey gang let's talk about that middle
class famous tour baby
getting bigger and better and it just
keeps her rolling on it's a live
stand-up comedy show plus we played a
little LRG with the crowd as I always
say great way to introduce new people to
the show so grab the squad and come out
and see us yeah guys in October we're
going to be in Nashville and then we're
headed up there to Indy then November
we're hitting Atlanta two shows added
there then we're headed to Charlotte we
got Philly Two Sold Out shows there I
apologize you snooze you lose then
December we're hitting Providence and
Boston those are currently sold out but
we're adding new shows stay tuned
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah a little
shall we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we found out they're going
to be classy Earth are just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Sully
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at Antilles basement I found
her sleeping upstairs oh God in the
refrigerator all right my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of are you garbage he's an
international businessman he's the
prince of Park Avenue but always the
king of the boards baby yeah give it up
for Mr Neptune
2005. KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure Yuri review subscribe over
there full video available on YouTube
free water ice as you know those numbers
are
and then obviously
um sing it sister
go ahead let him know Google
don't play dung with me what is this the
first 48 patreon.com God damn it yeah
slash are you garbage you're trying to
get bonus content you get episodes ayg
you get episodes of [ __ ] hard
feelings which is a completely different
thing you don't even know nothing about
unless you're a 10 10 homie shout out
and I we're doing a lot more uh behind
the scenes action on the patreon as well
we'll bring a new guy Luke out on the
road to film everything a little bit of
travel that whole night you know whole
nine yard green room stuff Hotel
Shenanigans me and you in the gym what's
up dog ayg 24 7. live streaming every
second of our goddamn live uh and then
we also just announced our new goal uh
the um
it's cooking it's cooking towards that
yeah we're gonna be at a [ __ ] Public
Storage yep get us out there
yeah we gotta go to an expensive place I
want to start but I want to bid against
you I'm gonna lay it all on the line oh
me versus you yeah we're spending the
same money that doesn't make sense
28 grand
what the [ __ ] opening bids 125. they
can't hold you to that what that fat
guy's not gonna chase us down the street
what are they gonna do with another
money how are we gonna do I know but
then you take me out of the storage unit
you don't get the thing then you don't
get the unit I get my socks somewhere
else um uh some people you're is that
what you're expecting to get out of
you're expecting to get personal stuff I
want to find something I want to find
like a like a World War II bullet or
something like that something cool okay
maybe a tank
those old guys they kept that [ __ ]
that's a replica full size
[Music]
um somebody said you gotta go to an
expensive neighborhood where a little
bit of cash oh yeah so you get there and
that's what people put in like oh my
record collection or oh my coin
collection or oh my whatever yeah nice
coin collection would be all right yeah
a couple maybe a couple of Lionel trains
yeah we already had people hitting us up
that can get rid of it for us too like
yeah I can [ __ ] a fence what do you
mean a fence what's a a fence a fence is
somebody that gets rid of the stuff you
stole is that a term yeah a fence I
didn't know how are you gonna fence it
okay but I didn't know the guy was a
fence or the lady yeah yeah they're
they're fences oh they can move
something I thought it was only a verb
you're out here fencing [ __ ] stolen
goods no you find a fence right okay all
right I saw heat all right uh that guy's
waiting on it so yeah I'm excited about
that gonna be pretty cool man that might
be the most well-received one we've
announced too A lot of people like it a
lot of people like it people are excited
I'm excited too we gotta get I might get
into it I gotta get gear for that too
sunglasses hats headlamps I'm getting a
big old flash we might have to get like
we're gonna throw in a pickup truck man
let's get like a dumpster drop depending
on how much [ __ ] trash is there we
are also or we could just search through
it if nothing's [ __ ] good plus we
gotta let's [ __ ] leave it we gotta
find some Cleveland six to roll around
with us be real nasty what do you mean
they always got some bird without some
scavots
bleach blonde hair a big set of cans on
her yeah distract the narrator or
whatever Cheryl or something how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaires I'm sorry we didn't even
introduced I'm speaking of big cans give
it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes I want to
complain about this for what the [ __ ] is
this what is this MC Escher will bottle
of water you gave me give me you bought
the water you gave me a limp noodle this
thing was melted down in some uh
Warehouse somewhere we bought the waters
you came in with the waters yesterday
and today and it's no name brand I think
I'm doing a late night set at filming a
special get this guy some Ritalin what
are you doing you're all over right now
this guy's nuts here you want mine we'll
switch
how much to drink this there's not
enough money in the world okay all right
50 bucks
I got a question for you fellas I'm
listening what's that T-Bone can you
have a raise no next question
is there any sandwich where you find it
appropriate to add ketchup I don't think
you asked me that yesterday
um
a below a hot baloney sandwich you'd put
ketchup on it a breakfast sandwich that
was the only one I landed on that I
think kind of works which can I say this
I'm not crazy about ketchup on my bacon
egg and cheese I'm not eating I'm okay
with it you know but you know what the
french do
the French we were talking about this
too because you were trying to find a
Savory pastry in New York City and I
said they got these joints these Paris
Baguette joints that are popping up they
dabbled a little bit the story is where
you want to find that because the Greeks
do that [ __ ]
and you said you wanted sausage but they
do have those ham and cheese in the
croissants now those Johns they do it's
kind of like ketchup it's like a tomato
paste those things are banging those ham
and cheese in a croissant last time you
had one of them because it sounds like
about two three days ago the way you're
the way you're describing this love
affair with the ham and cheese croissant
piece of ham Falls oh you're talking
charges are bogus and flakes flying
everywhere Oh They'll kill you talk
about evidence like coughed oh dude you
get one of those you one of those
croissants from from uh Dunkin Donuts
try to eat it in your car get out looks
like you've been cutting Lumber all
goddamn day it's hanging up on a wood
chip I know
yeah I would say a meatloaf sandwich you
put ketchup on no one's having a
meatloaf sandwich that's Insanity sure
yeah I mean sure I am I like a meatloaf
sandwich
you're the ex you're not the you're not
John Q [ __ ] taxpayer by the way I
think there's no pun intended but that
worked out two different ways you heard
extreme eater you pull up to buffets the
wingsuit on
yeah in a stream eater
thank you
what would you put ketchup on uh
breakfast potatoes exclusively
that's all you put ketchup on that's the
only thing french fries no mayonnaise
all right just that's right yeah he's
got that European in him he lived in
Belgium for a little while or something
like that didn't you Scotland yeah
different places but yeah I live in
Scotland where'd you picking up Scotland
Belgium small town where'd you pick up
the the mayonnaise trick I've read it in
a book or something as a kid sounds like
a real cool kid hey trog door kick rocks
will you I was wasting my time with
Cherry Magazine
that's where the rubber really hit the
road let's add a nudie mag oh yeah it
was no I read Next Level above Penthouse
I thought Penthouse was wild you get a
hold of a cherry you feel like a [ __ ]
guy
I wanted to say OB GYN but I was trying
to think of the right the correct word
for it what's the correct word for
gynecologist gynecologist thank you but
let's run that back real quick I feel
like a gynecologist wow
I read it I read that the original way
they did the palm fruit when they
invented the French fry they did
mayonnaise I was like that's weird I'm
gonna try that and I was like There's No
Going Back yeah it's all right it's fine
no no it's it's better it's I'm not
saying it's good I mean what's what's
the ultimate is the fancy sauce there's
a little bit of ketchup in that that's
that's craziest that's the best that's
the best of both worlds easy does it
you'll get your French fries Jesus
Christ right away take it back let's get
my favorite machine [ __ ] all right
it's a comedy podcast I was gonna say I
know this is
what the [ __ ] shout out to peanut oil
Five Guys that's how they do it I don't
like them leaving those sacks of
potatoes I never got that yeah storage
room yeah [ __ ] clean this place out
we're gonna have rats I feel like I'm in
the hole of a ship trying to enjoy my 12
Burgers
um what I was gonna say was I know it's
frowned upon and it's a trashy thing
however
if you're making a steak at home and no
one's around and you have a nice fresh
bottle of ketchup that hasn't been in
the refrigerator yet
it goes pretty good with a steak a
little Dippy it's not bad man I don't I
listen I don't I'm not yeah whatever but
I'm not a big steak guy but that's like
come on I wouldn't even do that and I'm
a [ __ ] Dirtbag eater I wouldn't do
that that's like that's a slap in the
face to the stake a little bit they'll
catchy we'll catch you on a stakey uh
only on ketchup is for children and
breakfast potatoes and that's the end of
the story I don't know you don't put
ketchup on your Eggies no that's crazy
talk that's nuts I don't do it either oh
no because some dippies and then you
chop them all up and you dip your toes
takes over because the egg is such a
delicate lightly [ __ ] fluffy
subtle piece of art and you're coming in
with [ __ ] ketchup just ruins it hey
Emerald kick rocks what are you talking
about that's true I don't know about
that a little a little bit of taste is
nice you're talking to a guy with an egg
tray yes that's true and also which I
wanted to bring up T-Bone got in my head
ever since he bought [ __ ] the uh
Aisha Tyler frying pans I went and did
the same I went and did the same these
been in my head my frying pan sucked
sure so I got new gear what'd you get I
got new I'm rolling around with new
steel daddy yo La croissant I mean come
on I mean we got I got two pots of those
we don't get frying but they don't do
frying pans no they don't their air
fryer is really good you got an airflow
water microwave was that George Foreman
Grill
um I got T Falls T-Fal if you've seen it
you know it that sounds like an
anti-fungal cream
put a little T-Fal on it you'll be all
right if you saw this you know
let me get you but I was when you were
like oh I got new uh uh whatever I was
like I had immediately gotten my head
that my [ __ ] sucked and it did because
that was the first stuff me and my wife
bought years ago like when we first
moved in together and we didn't like I
was living with roommates I didn't have
like cookware so we went out and bought
like uh okay cookware that was
four years ago at this point and I'm not
one for like I'm cutting stuff on it I
like the sure I get to get the steak
Knife I chop up my little chickpea or
whatever my side whatever I'm doing I'm
doing on the pan yeah I don't want to
dirty another plate or I didn't have a
cutting board I got Teflon that's no
good to get in your body or whatever
that is I remember cooking when I was in
college the plate I had these really
shitty pans and the black part was
coming off and sticking to the chicken
and I was eating it anyway and I
remember I called my mom like is this
stuff bad for you she's like I'm sending
you money you have to get new pants I
was eating the Finish
good luck having kids dude
Jesus Christ your kid's gonna be born
with a spatula in his head that's crazy
um these these Jones ah come on you
little [ __ ] you little [ __ ] box there
paid the uh the internet bill I did that
got shut down yikes it's got the red
circle in the middle like a t I gotta go
for that [ __ ] what do you mean you don't
go I'm not asking you to buy it off the
road
trying to move a set of [ __ ] but I did
get what I think is very classy I'm
trying to up my game I'm trying to make
my [ __ ] A little better I know you're
getting what you got one of those pieces
of wood that goes in the oven that you
cook salmon on it's like Hickory piece
of wood or something how much salmon you
think I'm eating I haven't eaten salmon
unless it's wild caught in a long
[ __ ] time he's about to tell you he
got his first spoon and you're talking
about blocks of salmon wood I need a new
set of silverware I lose forks I don't
know what happens to the man
probably in your titties dude we have
900 spoons 99 so you have Three Forks I
don't know where they go they must get
thrown out in like to go stuff or
something because I never used a plastic
stuff never at the house no that's the
worst uh no I got a square frying pan
it's really great for bacon dude it's
fan it's get I feel like [ __ ] Emerald
is cooking SpongeBob what's going on oh
it's great the circle unless you got a
big John Cuts you off with the cut to
the pass you got the flaps up on the
side of the wall good for pancakes oh
with the [ __ ] square John it's great
nothing's better than making scrambled
eggs in a brand new non-stick frying pan
oh you don't even need butter oh dude
it's great nothing sticks I'm like
calling my wife and I'm like look the
pants clean really I can put it right
back that's all right right back in the
cupboard but you get a couple of slices
in there that's when that's when you go
bad and start wearing off put it too
much scrubbing you're not supposed to
keep a tight ship in a kitchen you're
not supposed to use a metal spatula on
that either no it came with I got a
whole wood I got the whole set came with
plastic ah Plastics that we always burnt
them yeah but if you do it right yeah
true you leave it on the edge yeah wait
how how high are the sides because those
Square Pants can be shallow and during
that bacon gets diced real low it's real
low but I don't know if you know I'm
currently in a weight loss competition
so I'm only doing two maybe three pieces
of baking soda oil ain't an issue you
don't cook all the bacon
you wrap it back up and put it in the
fridge
yeah I think this describes the 170
pound difference between us I thought
you cook it and you just put it in a
Ziploc bag I didn't know you were
allowed to
can't re-wrap that up and put it in the
kit in the fridge are you making all
your bacon hold on hold on use you're
making all your bacon right Doug you
have the most insane relationship with
Home Cooking that's what no people are
making I don't I I don't think it's like
hot dogs you cook the whole pack you
cooked out now you're lying about that
you cook the whole package first of all
they're already cooked you don't need to
cook you just gotta heat them if to eat
we've never wrapped we've never
re-wrapped up bacon who's we the foleys
well it'd be one thing if you're cooking
for the family oh wait maybe she has if
you're at home and you're making
breakfast in the morning you're making a
whole thing of bacon
yeah you gotta talk to a nutritionist on
Sunday on Sunday
six pieces is a lot of bacon for one guy
to have well you that doesn't that's not
a resealable thing first of all they do
make them resealable yeah and also put
it in a Ziploc bag you said you have a
ziplock yeah you're touching that [ __ ]
no you do it all yeah just keep it in a
Ziploc and if you want to have it later
on you just microwave because you're
going to eat it that day if you have
made bacon in the house you're eating
that [ __ ] bacon yeah you are all
right now an hour I mean you know it's a
favorite snack almost two years of
talking about your weight loss to find
out you make slabs of bacon every day
yeah you cook all the bacon no if you're
making for the group yeah if it's like
there's four people five people eating
breakfast two and up
two people you don't make no
how many pieces of bacon do you eat
what do you have breakfast now two or
three and my wife might do one or two if
if but doubtful I'm making two or three
three I was doing six whatever would fit
in a pan yeah but that's when then
everybody started calling me fat so I
pulled that back
and now I'm down to two maybe tree you
know my move was when I was a kid well
all right so so all right hold on let's
man we're into it
you make you're just making for yourself
right your girl's out of town I wouldn't
make it for myself I would only make
bacon if there was somebody else with me
okay so okay it's you and your girl yeah
you and your lady yeah you make
breakfast Sunday morning whatever day
you got up we have the day off walk to
the grocery store I'm not doing bacon
during the week mostly I did bacon a day
you did we don't have nine to fives yeah
your call time was 2 p.m yeah but that's
a weekend thing you don't then what are
you doing during the week this morning I
made a couple Eggies I had a couple
Eggies and some fruit salad and some
green beans that were left over from
last night I had them cold a little bit
of balsamic just to get some greens in
me and a sheet cake
shout out to the sheet cake
it was Billy and 4C's birthday actually
wasn't crazy about those I like the
stacks
what
um so you and your girl you're making
the whole thing of bacon
that's 12 that's how much see how many
slices of bacon or let's say in a
hypothetical here all right if I went to
the store in the morning no weight loss
challenge no nothing no not 16 slices 16
slices of bacon that's a Baker's Dozen
right there
it's more than a Baker's Dozen I know
you it's my kind of Baker Lumpy's
let's just say go back let's go to the
pandemic okay no let's go to last
weekend we don't I'm not doing that
stuff anymore we don't do that there's
no bacon in my house we're not we're not
doing that crap okay you got to suspend
a little disbelief you gotta go back
when I was on my way up now I'm on my
way down when was the last time
everybody you're gonna sit there and
tell me you had bacon in your house in
the last three months
no I've not had bacon in my house in the
last three months I can say that
honestly I've ordered breakfast how to
get over there and dust for Hope friends
I found a snout in money yeah
a bunch of spider webs you go and
there's a bunch of live it's a pen a
bunch of live pigs winking around
it was Pig belly what do you want from
me which can kick rocks by the way I
have what pork pork belly that is the
dude you're an idiot I am not have you I
was I wasn't even trying to be funny
you don't like Ramen with pork belly in
it oh it's like candies oh so good yeah
no if you can kick rocks really big pork
belly guy believe it or not no way
really 18 pieces a day I do listen you
gotta cook bellies I did four bellies
you gotta cook the whole pig what are
you doing listen if we if if I'm in a
pinch in the morning and I don't do my
eggs in fruit and fruit salad We'll
order We'll order from uh leftovers
We'll order and I'll get like two or
three scrambled eggs and some turkey
sausage but there's no bacon how many
pieces of turkey sausage whatever comes
with it three four whatever they give
you that's okay
it's all protein
okay
there's no bacon in my house okay you go
to my house right now you're not gonna
find one okay one piece of bacon okay I
ate them all get butcher box baby
butcher box
your butcher box put your back man we
love butcher box I'll tell you that
right now gang do you like getting stuff
from the grocery store that's all flimsy
and mealy and gross how the chemicals
and hormones in there or what I feel
like having fresh top Quality Meat
delivered to your door that you slide
right into the freezer when you're ready
to use it boom it's right there for you
I'm talking about wild caught Seafood
I'm talking about grass-fed grass finish
beef I'm talking about free-range
chicken I'm talking about
amazing delicious Pork yeah guys you
mainly raise no antibiotics no added
hormones get what you want delivered
right to your doorstep free shipping for
continental US oh yeah and no surprise
fees choose from a variety a variety of
box plan options from curated to
customize take the guesswork out of it
yeah listen they know what everybody's
liking so they go do it here to Heavy
Hitters this is what you need
right in your butt the fall things are
getting busy let but your box take the
guesswork out uh guys like we've said 10
billion times I got ground beef I got
chicken I got steaks coming out the
Wazoo you want to come over for a rib
eye hit the kid up yeah but listen if
you're out there and you haven't used
butcher box yet be like ah let me uh
what are you gonna have tonight hey take
chicken breasts off your grocery list
dum dum because butcher box is All
Foreign there's an incredible deal that
they've never offered before guys write
it down free chicken for a year okay you
get two pounds of free range organic
chicken breasts for free in every order
when you sign up at butcherbox.com and
use code ayg claim this deal with
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg now do it yeah cutlets
all year okay let's talk about better
help baby better help I do this I get
caught up on the problem you know that I
know that I focus on the problem sure
instead of letting it go and focusing on
the solution that's right and with a
little online therapy you can start to
move your brain from focusing on the
problem to focus on a solution and let
me tell you something when that happens
it's a really really good feeling so do
yourself a favor get over to better help
because they can help guys uh I am now a
current client of betterhelp.com and do
you think I used our promo code bet your
bottom ass I did uh guys I've always
been a big proponent of talk therapy
I've said that for for well over a year
now it's helped me in difficult
positions in my life and now I need it
again to help me through some stuff
Daddio you're looking at me what cause
you're causing it I got couples to hurt
me for me and a big man uh no shout out
to uh Gary Gary's my therapist not
taking his first not telling you his
last name of course not
um by law I can't
um uh it's easy peasy it's fantastic the
rates are fantastic it's crazy it's
cheaper than traditional therapy I was
paying for to go sit in an office with
some Bozo now
healing from within I can't recommend it
more uh guys so when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can help
get you there visit betterhelp.com
garbage today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
help.com garbage do it join me uh all
right so paying that when you are making
bacon let's
all right now we're talking the pandemic
is what it's called when he cooks bacon
the fry pandemic
a frying pandemic getting myself swine
fluid so much listen
a typical Sunday breakfast would involve
go to the store dozen eggs thing of
bacon those Pillsbury uh Crescent
biscuits what yeah the biscuits slap
those in the oven some really good maybe
uh what's it Kelly's butter or what's
the marigold or kerrygold
yeah that's the real deal you get that
we get it for my mom buys it for like
Christmas and stuff has presents
stocking stuffers the kids love it
it's like a half and half for your bar
mitzvah
um
and some nice jelly okay that's and a
big thing of orange juice Tropicana
witch that has been in my house because
I was a little Sicky uh I put y's on
words you're 46 years old sticky eggy
ketchupy whatever just say the words
Eggies oh little Eggies listen
[Laughter]
you like cheese in your scrambies not
necessarily really I'm watching my
calories man but typically yeah I'm not
saying now relax Jack rolling we're
talking in perpetuity that doesn't make
any sense in the fantasy what you would
prefer is that what you think perpetuity
is something like that right no it's
moving forward all right moving forward
I get all the money and perpetuity no
perpetuity is backwards no that's
retroactive
anyway let's get back to the bacon
here's the oh yes you start talking
about jam and jelly here's the deal
those tropicana's kind of stink you
don't get a lot in those things
in the in the trap in the big boy
Tropicana get enough for one breakfast I
would say for two or three people
yeah but you're not three people there
well like this is what you do you might
have company you keep moving the goal
posts with odd language of like you know
ah two three four people you know
either way be that as it made that's the
breakfast and yes I do the whole thing
of uh uh Pillsbury rolls and the whole
thing of bacon all right and then you
pick throughout the day maybe
yeah that's not what you should be doing
um sure I understand that you asked me
what did I do in the past how I got this
no I didn't I was trying to get to how
many pieces of bacon you you [ __ ]
yeah you've started reading your grocery
list eight pieces when you sit
sure but there's a couple of you hold on
you're obviously you pull them off you
put them on a paper towel hold on it
doesn't all happen at once you do you
need two or three pans listen I I just
okay I get it stop for a second
yeah as you're making it I'm picking two
three pieces sure right let's say one
per batch
at least all right I'm gonna try the
goods I'll give you the benefit of the
doubt one per batch all right okay so
now let's say three by your three slices
in there
right before I even hit the table
I mean
the OJ even poured yet the eggs aren't
even Wicked oh the OJ Sport and the eggs
are whisk they're waiting they're in the
batter's box whatever
um I got the pan Hut
you guys right now to sink
[Music]
that's the Next Generation problem
you gotta you gotta you gotta stick
something to the Chinese when they take
over huh take my old plumbing will ya
um
so three there how many do you sit with
you put out you put the eggs on a plate
I don't care about anything else how
many pieces of bacon go on the plate
you just keep you try to like
romanticize now this is how I make it
how many pieces of bacon go on the plate
the plate that has the paper towel on it
gets sat on the middle of the table oh
you don't even put it on your plate no
trying to have a nice Sunday and enjoy
my day
watch my highlights wait till the
football but you play you'll take some
off your first serving
yeah how much is that
I love how now you don't remember you
just painted a huge Masterpiece of uh
Sunday morning for you two three you
know you start with that who you tell me
I said three kitchen now two go on
listen I'm not saying I don't eat too
much bacon all right so you're at five
there even if you took two let's say six
sure you're at six first course we're
eating the whole thing of bacon
you said you put it away no I said we
don't put it away
that's easy oh sure what now what are
you talking you started off with you eat
some of it you put in a place of bag you
eat it throughout the day now you're
going I eat all the bacon can I have a
sip of water please
oh my God it's mad and it's maddening
we don't put it away uncooked we cook it
all if there's some left over we'll put
the cooked bacon a couple of pieces that
are left over she doesn't eat all that
obviously so whatever her share will go
back into the refrigerator but to be
honest with you that's probably not
going to make it out of Sunday that's
not getting to work on Monday morning
sure that's going to get nibbled on
there's gonna be there's gonna be
missing persons out for that yes come
Monday morning because fresh cooked cold
bacon in the fridge is not is pretty
good and a nice clean little Ziploc bag
Patty does it really nice because she
cuts it in half
now you brought up the crescent roll I
did you know what's an unbelievable move
with the crescent roll to make a little
breakfast sandwich no that's good too
that's not too shabby you use the
crescent rolls to make your own little
pigs in a blanket
oh yeah I mean I don't do that though
but yeah do the homemades yeah okay of
course yes what a hot dog
these aren't the not the crescent rolls
the biscuits the breakfast biscuits
crescent rolls I would do with yeah no
I'm saying that we don't get the
crescent rolls we get the breakfast
biscuits this guy's lying all over the
flaky ones I just you that's like a
saying Band-Aid it's the terminology the
Pillsbury Johns
all right how do we get on this I don't
know you said you uh you were cooking
ask me how many slices of bacon I make I
said three
that's good yeah I'm not doing anything
like that anymore
okay no bacon
turkey sausage that's it turkey bacon
I'll do every once in a while okay that
stinks I also hate it yeah all right
I'm not doing any of that anymore you
came in overweight at your last weighing
so I don't try to act like you're on
your high horse that was years ago it
was 14 days ago
I don't do that no more meanwhile I saw
eating pizza rolls about [ __ ] 72
hours ago they were a gift yeah
yeah you gotta eat them all too
shout out to the helium Portland
helium hooking it up
um but that being said we got a goddamn
Family episode yes we do gang as you
know when you sign up for the old
patreon there you'll get a question
right on the air oh yeah it's the best
way to do it there's a bit of a backlog
so be patient with us that's what the
suits tell me I have to read that's our
disclaimer okay boys upstairs backlog
we're working through yeah all right
this one's just Kevin this one's from
Jeremy uh are you garbage if you tape a
leaf over your expired inspection
sticker to avoid tickets while you're
parked
that's a home [ __ ] that's genius yeah
man no that's not trash a leaf that's
trashy they uh this is supposed to be my
take one I guess it's trashy that you
let it last lapse and you haven't fixed
it but pretty [ __ ] genius that you're
taking care of it your own way and
you're sticking it to the man amen to
you Jeremy I saw a dude uh not that long
ago it was a pickup truck
I can't remember what he did he did
something oh I know what he did so in
New York you have the lane then you have
like those little those cones that you
can just knock over sure yeah those
things yeah that's like a [ __ ] mall
cop get out of the [ __ ] out of the way
and then you have the bike lane it was
all jammed up getting on the
Queensborough Bridge one day this white
uh RAM truck did the move it pulled
around went through the the bike Lanes
showing like bike lane in the shoulder
type thing into the intersection but you
know what he did when he before he did
it
had a little thing that that that hit
his license plate really dude it was
really sweet I saw it close and then
when he pulled through as he was driving
away I thought open back up man that's
like MacGyver shots like Night Riders
that's real Knight Rider stuff I had a
buddy do that when EZ Pass came out
couple of hippie dippy Pals I had
uh they were going on road trips like
Mountain claw like rock climbing and
stuff like up through like the
Appalachian Trail like up the East Coast
I guess you know it's like [ __ ]
Massachusetts or Maine or whatever rock
climbing I know what you're talking
about
um scaling some rock sure what are you
doing Manana freehand I'd do it free
solo free solo uh-huh plenty of tuna
fish keep slipping on a basin bacon
grease on my fingers tuna fish and
salmon salad I think no peanut butter I
know you don't like peanut butter all
right you don't like tuna fish so it was
salmon peanut butter and salmon salad I
think so there we go deep cuts on the
Seinfeld shout out to Dan Cortez uh step
off Foley step off
um so before they would get to the easy
pass because they want to pay the money
right a couple of Frugal Friends I got
uh they would pull over and put a
t-shirt over their license plate and
then just drive through and make it like
a mile pull over take it back off so
that way there's nowhere to send the Box
this was real primitive too this was
like early on and easy past days yeah
save you know whatever 50 bucks me and
my boy blew through a tie toll booth
yeah we blew through a toll booth uh
probably 95 96 going down to Virginia
um
we didn't have any money we just had to
fill out some form yeah you say I'll pay
you back later never yeah I lost my
wallet whatever whatever that I mean
like again if you do that's also old
school if you did lose your wallet I
don't have any [ __ ] cash I have no
credit card this is like pre then all
that
technology boom that's what you would do
yeah I forgot whatever and they you
write down they pull up they write your
license plate down and [ __ ] whatever
I don't know I don't know how they get
you yeah they really pursuing those
cases [ __ ] out of here I don't know
remember the ones you used to have to
throw the coins in they were big right
always got to do that if I missed my dad
would freak me out too that was I that
there was nothing that's like trying
that's being at the free throw line in
game seven dude that's [ __ ] pressure
uh two seconds left on the clock and
it's on you because it usually meant you
were close to your destination your dad
was dying to get there yeah
like I thought it was like that's it
we're leaving you here you you know
you're now part of the toll booth people
I remember them yelling each other
where's the change where's the ones they
said I only got a 20. going back and
forth we yeah but not that easy pass I
remember my uncle was a cop and they
always said no pennies they wouldn't
take pennies right the ones on the
Atlantic City Expressway in the term
like the ones in Jersey when you go down
the shore he's like yeah they don't take
pain he goes I know they do so that was
like our big like in the know
was they would take pennies it's like
it's legal tender they have to take it
whatever I love that they just don't
want to count them or something like
that but some dirt ball starts talking
about legal tender huh it's legal tender
you gotta take it
that's like when you say you can't pay
with change yeah
Constitution tells me I can't no one's
ever trying to break a hundred dollar
bill when they're saying legal tender
they're [ __ ] stacking nickels
looking for coins or the ridges on the
edge what a third ball
great question
yeah my uh my dad always used to get a
receipt too what get a receipt for 38
cents eight yeah it was for work there's
a business write-off
wow so I like I mean yeah I remember a
lot I remember my dad got out of the
Navy he uh he he started his own little
Insurance business and then started
working started working for Allstate but
he had his own little his own little
thing running his own shop yeah and dude
his [ __ ] console was filled get gas
she gas receipts so this received
receipts yeah [ __ ] it's all in the
credit card now that's why I use one
card boom but before it was Cash yeah if
you're paying Lee there was no easy pass
so you're paying like a dollar two
dollars and if you're doing that five
times four times a day it ends up that's
a big write-off 200 days a week whatever
yeah it's a Jihad off at the end of the
end of the year there you go sit in your
Puck that's legal tender though that is
legal tell you that right now
um all right let's see this was from
trogdor the burninator whoa
bad email Strong Bad Emails Strong Bad
email uh I've never had one red is it
garbage to store winter clothes in
suitcases during the summer
I mean John have you have any summer
plans you know you guys don't have any
[ __ ] trips to Aruba plan
if you can that's tough I get it though
it also depends on where
our last apartment was so [ __ ] small
before we moved to this one like two
years ago maybe was so [ __ ] small we
couldn't my wife couldn't keep sweaters
right she has like a bunch I hate that
that's one of the things that's starting
to get to me I mean I know I'm older and
you know been a bit of a loser most of
my life hey it's starting to get to me
the shoes underneath the underneath the
couch the [ __ ] stuff is under the
couch she has like a shoe organizer
under the couch because she doesn't have
enough places for her shoes that's a
tough law yeah dude you're using living
room
couches storage it's underneath the
couch oh you should have kept that one
to yourself she pulls it out it's all of
her shoes
got a lot of shoes though it's pretty
good
to work on a bigger apartment there
dubsy I think that's a cut back on the
bacon and spring for a three bedroom we
gotta get out yeah it's crazy that's
like up there with the Beanie Baby
organizer on the back of the closet door
that's very similar we have one of those
too I have one of those hanging in the
office where all my toiletries are my
shaving kit my contacts all that stuff I
keep something in the office yeah it's
on the back of the office I'm Gonna
Catch It by the way they're not checking
any toll receipts in there that is where
the kitty cat makes her dinker Do's I
imagine you sitting down with a bunch of
boba fetts like gentlemen we have
businesses
Round Table
you're walking behind them all sternly
and where were you on the night of
Boba Fett you fired
um
that's why Trump yeah shout out to
Boston Trump
[Laughter]
I'm not good with the Impressions what
did I try to do not that long ago I
tried to do an Irish accent or something
like that and launched it it was
Jamaican it came out as yeah yeah
um
we have I have one in the closet one of
those hanging Johns and I put some
clothes it depends like just overflow in
there kind of a couple pair of jeans I
don't wear it slide in there but we do
have a proper uh dresser it's just a
mess you know what on top of it
traveling kills me you know what proper
stinks they weren't good in college and
if you have one in your adult life it's
a real tough look I feel like I might
have one the plastic stuff oh dude you
pull out no they [ __ ] stink man
that's like a house of cards they'd come
falling down those things suck it's the
tops never level so and you put your
deodorant up there you bump it
everything falls over I hate all that
[ __ ] it drives me crazy okay let's talk
about ladder baby l-a-d-d-e-r yeah let's
talk about doing yourself a favor
getting yourself a little term life
insurance just in case the worst happens
you want to make sure that your family
is protected that they're taken care of
the things are done properly and Ladder
can help three million in coverage no
doctors no needles you do it all online
it's easy peasy and it's a good time
yeah guys listen a lot of you listen to
show or bozos myself included big man
bozos Bozo you probably haven't been a
stellar
husband wife son daughter whatever
you've Jane you've made some mistakes
along the way and this is one way you
don't want to stick your family leave in
the bag at the end of the line yeah I
owe my parents some college tuition yes
so this is one way to not screw them
over on your on your exit out you know
what I mean uh ladders customers rate
them 4.5 stars on trustpilot and they
made Forbes best life insurance list of
2021 baby
see in a few minutes a phone a laptop to
apply a lot of smart algorithms working
real time so you choose and find out if
you're instantly approved no hidden fees
you're allowed to cancel at any time you
get a full refund if you change your
mind within the first 30 days that's
because they're good peeps over their
ladder ladder policies are insured by
insurers with long proven histories of
paying claims they are rated A and A
Plus by am's best I'm not 100 positive
what that is but it seems good because
it's a flex finally since life insurance
costs more as your age Now's the Time to
cross it off your list make a move go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r lifetime dot com slash
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it uh
uh we just got like a nice stand up
what like the real version of that of
that sure like tall like she has her
drawer I have my drawer we got like a
drawer for the [ __ ] hand towels the
hair dryer it's nice good yeah clean
very crisp
um you use a hair dryer yeah you do
huh I do a little nervous I gotta try uh
I gotta dry the Rogaine as sexy as it
sounds really because if I put it on
because I put it on I'm running late
typically mostly or like I get out of
the shower I gotta put the Rogaine in
put the Rogaine in wet
you put it the way your hair is wet yeah
dry yeah dry my hair I like dry and then
put it in you put the rogain in after
your hair is dry
yeah okay
and then if I'm like chilling it's
whatever and then I'll just but if I
gotta go I gotta [ __ ] dry it also
gives a little volume too a little poof
to it you'll be hit me you would never
use the spray that fills it in I mean we
could do that as like a patreon bit or
something but I don't want to do it
Gippy gets hair I don't want to do it
because for a minute remember when they
were advertising that back in the day
yeah I think Bert says he's like I've
never done television without it that's
awesome he's big on it yeah yeah that's
good stuff just topics or something that
really fills it in man now I feel like
that guy punches sea monkeys on your
head yeah I feel like the magnetic guy
that you would draw the beard and
eyebrows on and stuff it just doesn't I
don't think it would look great hey
don't walk by the microwave for a couple
hours
did you do that on purpose when you were
a kid put metal in the microwave no but
you know I don't know if we've ever
talked about oh 100 I had to know what
happened oh no and we had these nice
china dishes I had to burn my parents
house down
can I say that China you just you call
China Fine China I think so yeah okay I
will take that out you not being sure
yeah we used to have these nice plates
that had a little bit of silver around
them sure and we put those in I I
remember that my mom was like do not put
that in the microwave I did that as soon
as she went to work I was like let's put
that in the mic I did that on
Thanksgiving by accident I was like
right here that's what we were like the
plates we were eating had that and then
I threw it into reheat and I do remember
the popping now it's really something
you know what was awesome as a kid we
used to do [ __ ] marshmallows in the
microwave they would blow up to get like
that big you put the Big Joe you put
like three jumbo Jaws in there yeah
I felt like [ __ ] Bill Nye the science
wrap one of those in Cobra Commander put
him in here I'll tell you what you want
to know you ever uh throw a CD in there
no you gotta lose some data when the
feds are on your Trail Jesus what are
you [ __ ] melting down hard drives who
are you it's [ __ ] awesome [ __ ]
Doug McRae over here
deep cut it's not what he did but sure
yeah they did they put it it was a
smashing grab guy they put the tapes in
the microwave in the break room at the
bank
um also too maybe like two three weeks
ago I get in the shower
and the water stops and I'm like what I
don't like that and I hear like that now
one of the selling points of the
apartment was the water pressure is
silkwood level it's okay powerful
caught a super oh Miguel the water
stopped he's like give me 10 minutes
they're fixing something downstairs it
has not been the same since I don't know
what they did that's not good they
probably put in de Blasio yeah
I'm gonna get a new shower head and make
the hole a little bit smaller to build
up the pressure isn't that what you do
oh I don't know well I'm getting a new
head anyway
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
um I need a lot of pressure who's gonna
put it on though you're not a man for
that job all right Teflon tape and stuff
sure a little Teflon tape in the house
we'll wrap that up put it in there I
don't believe you I'm telling you I got
vice grips the whole nine yards you got
vice grips monkey wrench needle nose
whatever you need I'm not gonna stand
here and be insulted by yeah
I got all that stuff metal saw hacksaw
Hammer yes I do there's no way I believe
that assorted screws flashlights I got a
a stud finder I got a level I got all
that stuff a bunch of mismatched screws
I'll buy yeah I got some mismatch
um this joint could use a touch up too
I'll come in here with the whole kit and
get all please
give you a good price too you're
charging me
time and a half though um make sure I do
it on Thanksgiving speaking of the
shower this is from TJ uh is the carpets
have multiple different scented bars of
soap in the shower so you can pick which
smell you want to smell like when you
wash your body that's clear I love that
that's [ __ ] clay I love that although
I did have a bone to pick
uh my wife went to like uh because she
makes fun of me because I use you know
generic not generic I mean like either
uh
Irish Spring guy or a dove like the bar
for like a dollar fifty can I tell you
something the dove bar is good it's like
milk yeah I've been really thinking
about
taking a step back and going Irish
Spring again oh there's nothing better
it just drives you out so bad you can't
do it in the fall man it's tough forget
you
um but so she was like she went to Lush
or whatever oh and she bought uh
she was there for something else but
ended up buying me like a bar of soap
like one of those blue bars the sub
looks like cotton candy Lush Bed Bath
and Beyond Sephora I'm all about spells
fantastic you walk in you turn the you
turn it on and invigorate like it like
wakes the bar of soap up like the water
so the whole room starts the whole
bathroom starts I mean it's not like a
technology it's just like whatever's in
it I don't know what you're looking at
me like it was space aged
really what do you got
is that the thing front on ethernet
what's happening no like just the smell
whatever they've used the soap's very
powerful yeah so like when you turn the
water on and the moisture gets in the
air like you can smell it before you get
in I'm like I [ __ ] loved it I love
that it was 15 bucks bar so yeah lasted
maybe 10 days it was just like I'm like
I got so much you sure it wasn't a bath
bomb
am I a [ __ ] [ __ ]
sometimes yeah I'm in charge of this
operation you think I'm showering using
a bath bomb
maybe maybe it was no it was a bar and
it's like literally like you would use
it like they're like Whoppers like dude
I would do my arm and it would be like
it would do like just watch it get
smaller and smaller I think you had a
bath bomb it wasn't a bath bomb you sure
yeah is there pumice in it pumice yeah
was it a Mediterranean dip no there
wasn't pumice in it that was a [ __ ]
bar of soap okay I did not think I know
what's I don't think you know what
you're doing over at Lush
that's what I think with soap
um but I was fewer I got out every day
but look how small this is you paid 15
bucks for this it lasted five six days
six seven days there's still a little
piece in the corner I can't bring myself
to throw it out I'm still sitting next
to the shampoo bottle it's legal tender
I could trade that in that's about 70
cents worth where did your soap go when
it was done in the turret
ours went right in the toilet I don't
know when it got down to like a little
tongue
but it looked like a laffy taffy it got
right in the toilet as a kid I guess my
mom just did away with it we put it in
the toilet I really remember shoving
some down the drain too get that out of
the way someone else's problem
I remember doing that because we didn't
have like the the holes we had like the
you pull up and turn it half
but was like uh was it in your drain
yeah they get the bath the shower oh it
was like a You Pull and turn it and it
stopped
huh I don't know if I ever read a
stopper
whoa yeah the rubber stopper would you
grow up in the 20s yeah you put that in
a rubber stopper yeah yikes yeah dead
bodies have been drained in that thing
yeah rubber stopper no but yeah you know
what I'm talking about you pull it up
and you turn and it stops but of course
sometimes I say stuff I know the the
switch no that's old school too yeah no
this is that never that they would break
so you can't use people start using
their feet to put the too much force
will snap that little you know what blew
my mind as a kid the release valve or
whatever it was right underneath that
the emergency valve so the toilet so the
tub doesn't overflow I think it's a
clean out yeah the over whatever it is
that little thing where if you got it
high enough you'd hear the yeah
I used to love that I don't think that's
an overflow drain I thought that was to
prevent the tub from from overflowing
now I'm pretty sure now
because I think I flooded my place with
that and now the the little that I do
know about Plumbing I think that's a
clean out okay A little [ __ ] filled the
tub up real high and jumped in there
like the Kool-Aid man I remember my my I
did I was just I it's probably seven or
eight I don't know I remember my aunt
making fun of me because I know what you
do up there you fill up the tub and you
start [ __ ] flopping around like Free
Willy and I was like oh that one stings
she goes and it goes and starts
splashing everywhere she killed Free
Willy killed you fat little bastard Free
Willy oh man when an aunt or Uncle made
fun of you for being fat when you were a
kid those really stung it didn't sting I
always like a good rip I like a good uh
good shellaccan you know what I mean
Free Willy yeah I know what you do you
get up there and start flopping around
does the stopper on your bathroom sink
work or do you have to go underneath and
pull the little thing I gotta raise mine
up a little bit yeah it doesn't come up
I think mine works we gotta we gotta we
got a drain problem though on this in
the sink my parents sink upstairs was
clogged for about 15 years really oh
yeah
yeah that we're kind of like that now it
gets bad after like a [ __ ] you know
what works really good to the sixth
floor these old [ __ ] buildings it's
just like you know what you want to do
go get Drano crystals oh I had I've done
it all baby you can only use cold water
That's How Strong they are you hear them
popping huh I've done it all day I guess
they oh they've expand that'll go
through bone like butter yeah we do it
but we we've tried it all man It's just
tough it's all [ __ ] Plumbing you got
to deal with it in this city stinks what
are you gonna do back in a country at
the Jersey nice house little picket
fence something nice
um all right this one's from Jose what
up homies first time long time is it
going to buy plus a plastic flask with
the intent of sneaking it past metal
detectors that's pretty good they used
to sell them that was my move
as a booze bag when I moved to New York
I'm like well I can't did you have a
flask
I have somebody did somebody rolled
around with a flask for a little while
I've definitely have cotton maybe had a
flask we all kind of did a little bit
Yeah like like when we first because it
was like we had no money Daryl Charles
shout out to him used to roll around
with one in the Raven days with uh
Pinnacle uh whipped cream yeah that was
his drink yeah yeah no but I would do
like whiskey or whatever just to get a
couple of you know because I'm like I
can't spend I don't have 50 bucks to
spend at the bar you know what I mean
I'm like I got I can wrap my head around
spending 30 or 20 do a couple of nips
you know take the edge off a little bit
when no one's looking I always hated
people to pregame with pre-game we're
pregame and I have something that was so
stupid but the idea behind it is so
solid and so genius why don't you like
pregame just the holy yeah dude pregame
is that how everybody says pregame in
your head in my head they do yeah but
pregaming's fantastic it is part of the
fun of the night it is it's better when
the pregame and you don't even go out
you're like let's just [ __ ] get more
booze and [ __ ] hang here this party's
cooking it's better from a pregame it's
better to show up to a dinner dinner or
a bar with a couple in you
I don't know it's also like if you're
going to a [ __ ] party right say hey
we're having Toby's having people over
come over at nine o'clock I don't want
to wait till nine o'clock to start
boozing when was this so Jazz over the
weekend really we had a little relapse
get-together did you really yeah it was
sick dude I stole a car what are you
talking about you're joking right
yes as an example he didn't relapse no I
know he didn't relapse but he might have
had you over have you ever been to
Toby's new apartment no
very upset I give you rides I better get
first dibs on the invite a couple of
games you think I'm giving you guys any
ammo what are you nuts I'm gonna break
in that's technically my apartment
somehow depending on this are you the
co-signer no I didn't need no cosigner
yeah kid's doing all right I may not
have faked a few employment letters oh
without question cut that what are you
doing that was for previous previous
places
[Laughter]
yeah the guy got the landlord got back
to me was like I looked up Tony LLC you
guys make desk Furniture right and I was
like yeah
I've never been honest on a [ __ ]
resume or an application or anything
like that it was pretty funny it always
juice enough he called he called me and
he's like yeah you know this was your
for your previous apartment or whatever
and I was like yeah I'll give you a
[ __ ] I'll I'll give you a [ __ ]
letter of whatever you need I'll hold a
mortgage if you want me to and he's like
yeah but you know to qualify by myself
because in New York have to make so much
money by yourself to qualify and he's
like well it's being done by the book
you get a landlord out in the story and
it plays ball sure he's in Santorini
half the year he don't give a [ __ ] and
he was like yeah you know I make just on
I'm like I'll make fake pay stubs I'll
[ __ ] do I'm like Alvin venmo me money
I'll put it in the books whatever we can
figure this out there's no way
paperwork's getting in the way you get
in the [ __ ] apartment buddy you got a
bunch of fake pills in the dryer with
some poker chips
figure this out dude best job I ever had
lost Fridays off
good stuff
um let's see here
um all right this one's from shower
shotgunner ten dollar hum yeah I had a q
red yet have you ever had to light your
stove with a grill lighter I've had the
light mine with one for over a year my
uh stove right now
it clicks nothing happens gas builds up
I start panicking that's when you go to
the grill later
really [ __ ] yeah
my one my one thing doesn't work get
checked out why
[Applause]
I hope you get a close-up on that cam
really
well the Pilot's lit hey relax you
should just have a working stove you're
46 years old but it's not going to fill
up a gas is it maybe
then the phone rings
that was always a fully that hits the
light man spark the phone yeah it's a
Fight Club isn't it I think it is yeah
yeah then the phone rings yeah and think
about all the fat around the house too
yikes
Bacon Fat
um
you know I think you should just have a
working stove sure how many burners work
three but now two
so two well that is if that is not the H
Foley spins up I can light it the gas is
getting to it the one the nozzle just
turns forever oh that's not good get
that checked out get a set of vice grips
on that turn that thing back you're
crazy
so you your stove only has two burners
working right now yeah how are you gonna
make a whole pack of bacon
[Music]
stuff
um I'm not done making fun of yourself
what are you you almost had me I'm like
all right let's whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
no call the landlord get a new stove get
him in there to fix how many burners do
you use at a time anyway I'm not making
[ __ ] Sunday dinner when I got four
things going I do one at a time
maybe two for the water for the pasta
that's it now we'll get three going you
get three going you know yeah if you're
doing some sort of what are you making
mashed taters we'll do it they do really
uh
I've been on a baby you didn't invite me
man I've been thinking about mashed
potatoes lately we'll do a sweet pea Mac
she'll do by hand a sweet or a sweet
potato mash oh that's really good she's
good she's she can throw down you know
what's really good uh uh I want to say
it's calabasa I think it's like pumpkin
but it's a little bit uh I'm not a fan
of a pumpkin squash World kick rock well
this is this is like sorry I'm a girl
this is pumpkin but it's not as sweet
and this place I used to work out they
used to put Garlic in it and make a make
a like a pumpkin Mash
it's all right so all right uh but we
gotta wrap it up gang thank you so much
we love you gang we love you come see us
on the road check out the patreon grab
some merch subscribe over there on
iTunes subscribe on YouTube dude show us
a little love we love yous baby we love
you and we'll see you next week